tu baises ma soeur tu as baisé ma soeur
oh mon dieu oh mon dieu ce que j'ai vu ce
[ __ ] m'a laissé une erreur totale que je n'aurais
jamais dû savoir je suis tellement désolé
il y a quelque chose de beaucoup plus grand et nous sommes
là Hannah je suis  tellement désolé je sais pour
le préservatif dont Hannah parle
j'ai trouvé le préservatif que faire c'est une
[ __ ] d'averse elle a essayé de voler
mon sperme en essayant de voler ton sperme
Hannah non oui pourquoi yo j'essayais
j'essayais de tomber enceinte de Jack non  pas
jock avec quelqu'un ouais moi tu vas être
tu n'allais même pas connaître un petit
sac en plastique et être jeté à la
poubelle exactement où le sperme appartient pour qu'il
ne devienne pas un [ __ ] de bébé que je
ne connais pas d'accord alors ça  laissez-moi
juste clarifier cela, vous pourriez potentiellement
être enceinte de son bébé